[Music]
i really do want to get married i mean
selfishly i just really want to have
that like one big day about me i can't
wait for that um and to wear a dress but
i do want to marry artem
um but the one promise that i've made
him before we can plan is that his
parents can attend and with where the
world's at right now and trying to get
two russian parents into the country
it's almost impossible so
the day i can get two visas is the day
we will set our date
nikki and artem's son mateo is one now
and the question they're hearing a lot
will there be more little ones in the
future this is what i told darden look
at 39 if i'm happy where i'm at in life
and with you
i possibly will get pregnant and let's
try to have that baby before 40. but hey
if not i'm sorry
she's closed
she sees how chaotic my life is i do i
mean honestly i'm so content with one i
look i walk in her house and sometimes i
look at me 10 i'm like dude we're out of
here let's go back across the street
listen classical piano music and chill
because her house is so chaotic oops i
almost poked you in the eye bed the 38
year old bella twins moved to napa
valley a year ago and live across the
street from each other which is
particularly nice when brian and artem
are out of town for work it's really
hard um super lonely and i think it's a
lot harder now just because being a mom
and like i see that my son misses his
dad but i'm just so proud of what artem
does he's just such an incredible
ballroom dancer one of the best in the
world so i'm so proud of him at the same
time i mean this is my husband to tell
you honestly
we literally said the other day we were
like should we just buy one big house
together yeah we better make our lives
move again but we kind of had that idea
to our men and they were like yeah no
but we're like it'd be really easy for
us because what we'll do is we'll do
dinner at each other's houses with the
kids or coffee before bird goes to
school like we have our little things
like that because it does help to help
each other with the kids it's nice but
even when their men aren't around nikki
and bree still find time for twin dates
sunday is our day where we get to go
wine tasting or do something fun yeah
and they were on board with it and we
just got to decompress and it's so nice
so fun fans can hear all about their
daily lives on the bellas podcast after
a six-month hiatus there are new
episodes dropping wednesdays on
siriusxm's stitcher what up everyone
it's nikki and bring did you all miss us
because we definitely missed you we just
really wanted to take the summer off
kind of hit a refresh button kind of
think what else we want to do with the
show make it better and bigger now we're
back baby as for a potential return to
reality tv we obviously don't want our
kids to be growing up on television we
love reality tv we love being reality
stars and i think reality isn't done for
us as a duo and entrepreneurs and
whatever it is we're doing but as far as
our
relationships and our families like
that's where we've realized we need to
take that off television
[Music]
you